okay so feel free to play along at home
uh let us know down in the comments
below what you think about uh all of
these what do you call them like traits
traits quot traits traits however you
want to call they're traits traits you
know if you were to play an RPG and they
had these you would see them as good or
bad okay sure sure so let's your
character frequently get drunk that's a
bad trait to having a character that you
want see this is going to be interesting
cuz I don't think I've ever actually
like sat down and about whether
something is green or red flag you know
yeah and there's a lot of things that
you know I think when you're if you ever
if you're fortunate enough to ever get
in a relationship you learn
that did you say cuz God knows our
audience will never listen listen hey
come on all right I'm right here fans
having girlfriends and boyfriends going
to represents the every man here he's
the every man listen that's a red flag
you know it's easy to be like I would
never date someone who has this you know
a lot of the time life is a lot
different than that you know sometimes
you date someone you find out afterwards
that they they like to think the world
is flat and and then you know that's a
kind of conversation you got to figure
out afterwards and I feel as well like
Flags change all the time depending on
what stage of your life you are some
things you can be way more tolerable
about other things you just like what is
look how bouncy this thing is oh my Lord
the
[__] you're like a little kid now what
the hell what the heck it's so bouncy
ladies is that a red flag or a green
flag that's that's a that's a beige flag
right there pull it out of the damn all
right all right all right let's see all
right here we go our first one is are we
writing it down then then yeah we I'm
going to read it out and then we write
it down and reveal okay here we go
here's our first flag our first flag is
has the food pallet of a
12-year-old isn't that just all of us wo
w
okay do not put words in my mouth sir
okay okay okay holy [__] what what what
does food pette of 12-year-old mean see
that's open for
interpretation you can you can interpret
that how where you want how do I spell
beige is that well thanks for telling us
well I just realized b e i g
e I wish I got that one ining I got that
one right
illiterate okay we get it okay we get it
all right we get it yours is beige all
right ready let's reveal in 3 2 1 it's a
red flag red flag flag why is it a red
flag okay I mean okay I'm I'm surprised
not all of us wrote down actually I'm
not
surprised okay first of all beige it's
not it's not a quirk to not [__] eat
anything everyone has a [__] Quirk
about something that's weird with their
taste buds that is that is that is not a
weird thing you interpreted that in the
I get we're in trash taste if you
interpreted that sentences you have the
power is AKA you have one thing you
dislike I don't think that's how I
interpret what is your definition of uh
taste what was it I I interpreted that
as they have the palette of a
12-year-old yeah pal of a 12-year-old
they won't eat most things you go to a
restaurant they're not willing to try
stuff you know that's like a a big part
of for me is that I like being able to
sit down and share meals with people yes
and if they're not willing to at least
try certain things hey I get it if you
don't you straight up don't like oie you
know you don't like oi and it comes out
okay that's fine we get that it is this
is linked to one of my biggest pet
peeves not just with Partners just with
people in general people who don't like
put all of the judgment on something
that they have little to know
information or knowledge about and don't
even bother trying to okay okay just I
guess I guess there's like a way to
interpret it but how picky are we like
saying right now how picky are we
talking about well will picture your
average 12-year-old uh at a restaurant
or something right they're going to
probably pick the most like when I was
12year old I wasn't [__] exploring
food or anything they probably always
eat the same thing they tend to be like
you know ordering with them is is never
fun like I think fun part of alling when
we all go out like what are you feeling
and we all just kind of try a bunch of
things yeah it's like oh I've never
tried that thing before I'll give it a
go sometimes you go out people and
they're like I will only eat this one
thing and you're like oh okay I mean
that's F or they're like super specific
about what they can eat because they're
comfortable with it and that's fine like
as as it makes it sound like we hate
these people I don't there's no like
nothing wrong with it but it's like for
me if I was to be with someone that's
something that I would care about is
being able to share those Foods as
someone who uh you know famously [__]
with everything in terms of you do [__]
with too much though I love that there
are some things you shouldn't [__] with
Joey no but like you know for me it's
like if you tell me that if I go to a
new country or something and you and I
see this like particular Cuisine that
I've never heard of don't even know what
the hell it is right cuz it's might be
in a completely different language I
don't know right never seen anything
like it before if the locals tell me
that it's good [__] it's edible you know
it might differ you know some people
like it some people don't that just
pequs my curiosity of being like well I
want to try this thing out I want to
explore you willing to try something
yeah I'm always willing to try something
out before I judge something you know
okay yeah I I agree with that then I I
would not be with someone if they
weren't willing to like try other things
yeah what if what if Sydney only ate
chicken nuggets which is a because she's
from Wisconsin which is a possible time
cheese curs what if she only ate chees
she only ate like cheese curds and Fries
I've not met a single person that is as
bad as what you guys are talking about
though you never met I've met so many
people I have I have not I have like
even even I'm going to like you know
deep into like Wisconsin people are
willing to try out new things you know
they they might not always like it but
people are normally willing to at least
try something to be like nah just give
me a burger and cheese and cheese curs
I've met people who only like fast food
like they will not out of Preference
they just don't like anything else and
they're not will I understand
if most of the people I'm not I'm not
trying to be like because we hate
Americans so much I'm not trying to be a
dick but it was most of the time people
I meet who are super picky are normally
American however I have met a bunch of
British people who also are [__] in
this I've met some Australians who are
like this you know the way they just
like they just not willing to try prence
preference to preference I'm also around
Americans the most I I'm around more
Americans are not so I feel like this is
also why my judgment skewed yeah but
like you know I get if like allergies
are involved right like obviously you
can't if you're disease or you eat
certain food or something that is
physically stopping you from eating or
if there's something physically stopping
you like at a chemical level of you not
being able to eat a certain thing yeah
you know then I understand your immune
system just hates you it's just an
immune diff then I get it but like if
you look at this thing and you're just
like the one thing I okay this is one
thing that this pet peeve I hate the
most is when something comes out and
before they've even tried it they go
what is that yeah and then they try and
know every single little detail and then
after hearing all the details they're
like no I'm not going to try okay but
sometimes sometimes there are things
that you you know you don't really have
any interest in wanting to [__] with
like would you would you feel that way
if someone's like n I'm good at ever
trying Nat uh no I think I think you
should give anything a go and if you
don't like it then now you know it's
like you try it once you don't like it
okay that's completely fine that you
don't like I'm not going to hate
everyone who doesn't like Nat obviously
but like I'm going to hate you even more
if you say you don't like Nat without
even trying it out because as we've
found out you used to not like Nat and
then you tried it on after dark and you
[__] with there is some kind of like
psychological thing though where you do
you like almost fearing this food so
much that there's no possible part of
your brain that will allow you to think
it tastes good or the texture is good or
whatever um and I I don't think that's
the thing but yeah I mean if I go to a
restaurant and like 50% plus of the
things you don't want to eat or you're
not willing to try I'm like okay well
then what like you know CU for me that's
a lot that's like how I that's a lot of
my downtime is being able to share those
totally yeah um we're very fortunate we
get to we get to go out yeah I mean I I
I say this because okay so as long as
they're willing to try things that's why
I didn't I didn't put like I didn't put
like red flag because you put nothing
you put no flag I I guess you could just
put no flag okay no no FL you made it be
like oh that's a weird thing like like
okay the way I interpreted that is like
taste Buzz of a 12-year-old right that
means they just haven't gone out of
their comfort zone for like a lot of
things cuz I remember when I first
started dating Sydney she had not really
had anything but like American foods and
she could not handle spicy food like at
all right yeah so you know you could
argue that she had not had a lot of
different cultures food and now like she
eats spicier food than my mom because
she started okay but spicy food I think
is a bit different cuz that's not a
taste that's a
sensation maybe to a Japanese person
Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey I think that is
very different I think in terms of the
palette of a 12-year-old is like we are
really going into the
definition no no no I'm not I'm not
going to let I'm not going to let this
one go yes okay Joey scientifically
whatever spiciness isn't a taste all
right Joey but you know if if you can't
have spicy food um like even to like
just a little bit of a spicy food me as
a tie I'm going to think that you're a
little baby that can't eat anything with
a little bit of spice he look I'm
someone who got out of that comfort zone
I used to not be able to eat any spice
growing up is a gradual thing it is grad
and now I would say I'm pretty all right
you know Coco level I can go up to a
level four now no because proud of that
because like here's here's the thing
like I think we like met someone about
like that thought this earlier but it's
not just the spice but it's like how
sensitive is your palette as well right
so some people can't handle Southeast
Asian food for example because it has
like a very very strong taste love it
and and you know I love it I love it
right but some Japanese people that I've
met and you know some some wessners that
I've met as well that tast is just like
this this going to sound so weird
there's just too much seasoning there is
just too much seasoning and like to me
I'm and to me I'm like okay that's the P
of a 12-year-old to me as a Southeast
Asian are you referring to one of our
staff going to nandos for the first time
the other
day maybe but he is not the first person
I've met that has said that but context
one of our Japanese staff here at uh
trash taste went to a nandos the other
day in the UK and his review of nandos
was there's too much
flavor that's [__] up is [__] [__]
up that's [__] up say so that's a
skill issue let's go let's do the next
one pull the next next one can't stand
too long on the [__] 12-year-old
topic it doesn't matter we we can do
this for as long as we want to uh is it
a red or green flag when they don't use
social media H
[Music]
okay okay I'm going to I'm going to need
context I'm going to need I'm like I'm
thinking about these and I'm like I need
I need some I need some
context okay what what [__] that is
the context that is the context they
don't use social media okay is there no
Twitter No Instagram no Facebook nothing
nothing what you can call social media
they do not use the only thing that I
think I will like I I I when I think of
social media I don't count stuff like uh
messaging or like line whereas it's
strictly peer-to-peer communication
people they can text you but you can't
find them on a website I know that is I
know that is technically the definition
of like social media or like social
inter is iset but I consider that as a
completely different app yeah but if you
include that then like snail mail is so
yeah right like I think no one no one in
their right mind even though the
definition includes all of these like
would compare like texting to being on
Twitter like it's it's not specifically
talking about social media websit okay
ready 3 two one beige oh green I I
decided to put green I listen I I'm
terminally online I I don't want someone
who's also terminally online okay so for
me this is I I thought about green at
first because obviously we in a position
where like social being on social media
is part of our jobs right like we kind
of have to be on social media as public
figures on the internet but I think I
thought at first it might have been
green because there might have been like
a nice like if your partner doesn't use
social media then that's a good excuse
to like kind of lay low on the social
media and kind of cool off on being
terminally online all the time but at
the same time a lot of like my cultural
references that I know a lot of like
memes and stuff like that also comes
from social media I love would I be able
to like have a fun human existed before
social no yes but admittedly a lot of
that human now is rooted in social media
I don't know I think I don't know you
that's like saying hey I can't get on
with my parents cuz if I say Among Us
they're not going to understand what I'm
talking
about and I would argue actually that's
a good thing yeah that's a good thing
that's a good
thing par to know I pull the we of three
people's social media usage I don't need
another person doing it I don't even
think you do there are there are more
people nowadays that are more terminally
online than there are that are not I
think it's just like how you spend it
online like I streaming all the time
it's just different hours like I don't I
don't actually have that much time to
scroll all the time but I'm just always
online in some capacity so I feel like I
I would like to get away from that when
possible I think I think I put down
beige because in the sense of like don't
yeah it is weird in this day and not
have it it is very quirky they had to
made the choice to do it yeah a little
try Hardy if you ask me right well
depends how they're framing it like if
someone's like I'm not on social media
and it's like okay but do you know
anyone around you who's not on social
media I know some people yeah how how
how did they like look at social media
uh they just they just kind of okay they
just kind of look at it as a negative
and they just want to live in the moment
I guess that's what they said they I
think they want to be more focused on
the things that's immediately surround
them as opposed to what everyone else is
doing unfortunately makes it harder to
get in contact with them uh sometimes
that's like I guess the biggest downside
but the reason I put green flag is
because I was thinking about it and I
was like if someone told me they didn't
use social media can I think of any
negative effects yeah I think there's no
down yeah I don't really see any
downside to someone not being on social
media a lot self-confidence generally
cuz you're not on it you're like I feel
confident in who I am I don't need to be
in this game of of clout see because
like that is definitely a good thing as
well but at the same time it's like you
know I think the benefit of you know a
partner and you being on social media is
that you can like say for example like
you know something that everybody does
nowadays which is just like sharing
memes or just like bringing up something
fun that you saw on social media or like
something funny like a funny video or
like a funny Instagram just show them on
your phone yeah it's not you're going to
show them like no no I'm allergic to M I
can't look at Instagram
but Fades away
like stop melting but I think you know I
think the benefit of being on social
media is you know again it's totally
depends on how you use it but I think
just having that like same even just
like Baseline knowledge of how social
media like memory works and how the
internet works and stuff like that
internet culture works is just a very
nice way to be able to connect to your
partner you know whereas like if you
show them like a [__] meme on
Instagram that has like0 layers under it
which a lot of memes nowaday do have
then it's not going to be really fun
when you show them a meme and they're
like I don't get it you know it it get I
think in the long run it'll get
difficult so that's why I put Paige okay
well I think valid arguments all around
I don't agree it's a personal thing you
know it's whatever I mean I I don't need
memes to I you know I I don't there's
more ways to connect to if I don't show
a day I will die that's all I'm saying
Joe's like you do have the most
extensive meme collection I say out of
the three of us me yeah I think so yeah
I I gave up I thought it was you for I
gave up on memes a while back actually
really well I keep up with them but I
don't I don't collect or make note of
them why why is it a that I collect
memes you do keep I do not save memes
for lot like you save memes you
sh yes you sh sh I don't share memes
anymore I gave up right oh that's just
because I'm on Instagram
yeah all right